foreign
it comes from Rick in New Mexico he says
we're in our early 30s make 120 000 a
year and we're financially stable we
want to buy a house but with high prices
and interest our mortgage would be
roughly 2200 a month we could afford the
payments but that's less we are able to
save my parents own several rentals are
financially stable and want to buy us a
house so we would just pay them rent to
1400 a month instead of us buying a
house
they said once we pay it off with no
interest they will put my name on the
house but the problem is my father can
be controlling and historically after
doing something nice he has been known
to throw it back in my face down the
road if he doesn't get his way or if we
do something he doesn't agree with
should we take my parents help or do it
on our own Rick you know this
the question you and your wife need to
ask yourself is what's the price of your
marriage and what's the price of your
soul
and what's the price of that
Thanksgiving dinner when your dad looks
across the table and says why didn't you
do this and you say well Dad I was and
he goes I bought you a house
what's that all worth what's that worth
because the numbers you've laid out for
me it's not worth that
it is not worth that you make too much
money you're doing too well
um for you to subject yourself
to somebody else bullying you around
just because
um there's some the you know there's
some money attached to it yeah I'm not
doing the strings attached deal and he
he's already painting the picture of
what his life is going to be like if he
does this deal and so I think you you
just need to say hey thanks so much for
the offer we're gonna go our own way and
buy our own house uh but we appreciate
you guys and you guys make plenty of
money make 120 000 a year 2200 sounds
like a very reasonable mortgage payment
and uh if you feel like it's too high or
for some reason we're not getting all
the details here you can do something
called waiting and you keep saving until
you have more down payment to lower that
mortgage payment so do it when you are
ready but don't be bullied into it don't
be pressured into it and because that is
the worst thing you can do financially
and let me say this uh Rick
and everybody listening it's often that
I hear situations like this where Mom
and Dad want to help but there's a
there's these subtle strings or really
significant strings and all that
attached to it
I'm gonna give you this but you got to
do this and if you ever do that I'm man
I just I don't want that life right
um and then we turn around and feel
pressured on the advice side why aren't
y'all buying a house y'all gotta buy a
house I'll just rent and just waste of
money just throwing money away throwing
it away throwing it away and so if some
if you're not gonna take the deal
because you don't trust the character of
the people involved in the deal right a
gift won't be a gift a gift is just
another way to put Hooks and string into
you
don't also fall prey to their advice and
wisdom about how dumb you are with your
money you and your wife sit down and say
what kind of Life do we want to create
for ourselves and can we create that
life and what do we got to do to make
that thing happen it might mean like
George said it's gonna take two years
before we buy a house cool we don't want
it to we can afford a 22 a month payment
we don't want that we don't ever want to
payment more than 17.50 whatever cool if
that's what you all decide rock and roll
we're gonna rent a little bit longer
then and save up a little bit more we're
going to take a few more shifts or
whatever that looks like but don't take
wisdom from people that are not
trustworthy and the other danger of this
is you guys pay 1400 a month for 10
years and all of a sudden he decides you
know what I'm actually going to use this
as a rental property because we need the
money in retirement and all of a sudden
you've been putting money into this
thing that you don't actually own right
and so that's super risky I would not
take this deal or a little Junior
decides he's gonna play soccer instead
of baseball and my boys are playing
baseball I'm taking whatever you don't
know baseball family you don't trust
this guy yeah no deal no deal deal no
deal I keep renting man your your
marriage and solar worth it